40 000 c'est notre chiffre du jour il
s'agit du nombre de visiteurs qui ont
participé ce week-end à la vingtième
édition de vitilloire la Fête des vins
en plein air une influence record
boulevard Heurteloup à Tours il faut
dire qu'en plus des 150 viticulteurs
présents la météo était également de la
partie notre journaliste romain Delville
a lui aussi répondu présent regardez
Cabernet Franc et Malbec millésime 2022
20 ans le bel âge pour vit-il war pour
Bruno la manière de fêter l'anniversaire
de l'événement c'est de charger le
diable et ramener plein de souvenirs
dans la Manche le département en général
on file sur certains stands qui sont
déjà
présélectionnés
la gamme de ce qu'on va de ce qu'on va
tester ce couple americano irlandais
installé à Saumur profite d'un week-end
romantique pour faire un tour des caves
en un seul lieu c'est une célébration de
l'anniversaire de mon mari qui aime
beaucoup les veines de France mais
surtout les vins de Loire et surtout les
22 Saumur beaucoup de vins de 107 au
monde oui de vrai
20 ans de vitilloire c'est aussi se
poser la question de l'évolution du
marché des goûts et du marketing mon
compagnon c'est la quatrième génération
qui est et en fait savoir voilà essayer
de d'attirer un peu plus la clientèle de
ramener en fait nous notre pâte par
rapport à l'exploitation dans l'hôtel de
ville justement place est faite aux
nouveaux vignerons Julien Martin par
exemple a créé le domaine du mouton noir
sur l'appellation Vouvray après avoir
rouler sa bosse dans des domaines de
Sancerre Chablis Cheverny ce jeune
vigneron s'est installé à son compte
première génération de viticulteurs je
pense que surtout quand on s'installe et
qu'on a pas un poids familial qui est là
on a une certaine liberté de de vrai et
de choisir des choses qui peuvent être
peut-être un peu plus audacieuses et un
peu moins traditionnelle qui fait qu'on
n'a pas de frein et voilà qui va être un
peu plus compliqué quand on est sur une
reprise familiale classique 20 ans de
vieilloise c'est l'occasion de se
souvenir se souvenir de ceux qui ont
plus créer un salon des vins populaires
évidemment on pense à Jean Germain
l'ancien maire de Tours qui a initié
cette manifestation qui a voulu que
vitilloire existe
j'avais une pensée ce matin pour à la
Irlande évidemment qui nous a quitté il
y a quelques années et puis
comment ne pas parler de Jacky blow
Jacky Blot un grand vigneron qui nous a
quitté malheureusement il y a il y a
quelques jours seulement et son domaine
et toujours présent depuis les débuts de
beethy War du patrimoine des nouveautés
des maisons historiques comme des
domaines en devenir il y en a pour tous
les goûts et de toutes les couleurs dans
ce salon des vins à ciel ouvert